I really shouldn't have gotten this
coffee because I already feel like I
have to poop and that's like not
conducive to meeting new people hi I'm
Jared and I'm a video editor for busty
Jared is always very aware of what
people are thinking about him or the
perceptions that people have of him I've
kind of hit a block where I'm not
feeling any better about myself new
people scare me so much he has a kind of
grungy look to him I would describe him
as like hobo chic he's still really
surprised
whenever anyone wants to hang out with
him so I figured it's time to get some
help so I found a style and confidence
coach to help me overcome my
insecurities over the next week what's
up man hey Gianni Garrett nice to meet
you this week you want to improve your
image get you style up and you want to
increase your confidence 100% where
would you say that these problems what
did they like stem from when I was in
high school I had this huge crush on
this dude that I thought was like super
beautiful at the time I was like a much
heavier guy and I said to him like hey I
was wondering if you want to go the
movie sometime and he said oh that's so
sweet
I would love to date you if only you
lost like 20 pounds that's probably
where a lot of my reluctance to accept
myself for Who I am comes from [ __ ] them
now you know to me [ __ ] them and [ __ ]
what they think to think about people
with it's not always about physical
appearance it's also just like your
energy your presence what you give all
that attracts them to if you really just
take the notion of not giving a [ __ ] and
just start random conversations with
people it will build your confidence in
such a way that you could be like the
life of any conversation just before the
rest of your life after meeting with
Jionni I called up my best friend Nicky
to give me some challenges that would
force me out of my comfort zone without
killing me okay so we have three
challenges laid out so first challenge
you're gonna go talk to strangers at
least three of them know yep where is
everybody
there's no one else here to talk to
house number two your new photo shoot
very fancy but it's gonna be in an
outfit that you never felt like you
could pull off but you're going to we're
having fun I'm not thinking about it
card challenge you're gonna throw a
party what's where this is
and at least for a little bit of a party
you are going to be the life of the
party let's help you out a little bit we
did talk to some people in the office we
really do believe in you know I thought
Jared was cooler than I was and he had a
mustache for God's sake I would say that
he's amazing and he just needs to
understand why and sort of carry himself
knowing how amazing everyone else thinks
he is he comes off as confident and cool
and put together and he just needs to
believe it to be it
I think Jarrod has a lot to be confident
about he's a really great editor he's a
good friend he's funny he loves his cat
I think that Jared's gonna look and feel
great at the end of this week you are
you and they love who you are and maybe
with a little bit of help you can be
someone who feels great about themselves
today so I'm gonna go talk to some
strangers feel like Oh awkward person
Hey how's it going not too bad I love
your search where did you get that from
oh my god yo bye hey dude
do you like that phone I've been
considering the edge yeah have you
dropped it at all no because I like I'm
always dropping [ __ ] waterboxx
yeah well thank you for your serious
funding common interests common ground
he wasn't weirded out by that so that's
cool hopeful hey man how's it going
you have an OK day having a pretty
stressful day actually anything positive
happened today though
okay I will mind my own business that
dude at the bus stop ruined the whole
thing for me holy God as soon as the
camera shut off I like shut down and I
was like barely I barely did anything at
work the rest of the day cuz that's just
like emotionally exhausted on our way to
the mall now and I realized that I don't
have a clear vision on the outfit that I
want to purchase did you got the height
you don't really got to add too much to
it you know what I mean and obviously I
feel like you should lose the head to
soar yeah not a security blanket in any
way shopping always stresses me out just
because it's when I feel most
self-conscious with my body like
throwing things on seeing that they
don't fit seeing that I'm a large when I
like wish I was a medium that kind of
thing but once I did find the right fit
pants and the right jack in the right
shirt I did feel like pretty badass so
now we're gonna go throw this stuff on
and take some photos
my name is Maci and I'm a senior staff
photographer at BuzzFeed today I'm gonna
try to get Jerrod comfortable in front
of the camera I like this dude I like to
do this like ah just in front of a bunch
of cameras about to get my photo take
that will not be a problem no it's
embarrassing anytime that I'm like
taking photos of myself I'm never like
just confident in what me looks like I
love
go do with my hands no think about what
you want to portray in these photos
confident Jared is not too cool for
school but he's like happy and fun and
but also cool it would be pretty dope to
have like one of those Untouchables
photo
first of all Tilly was I feel like this
whole outfit is like a dude it was worth
it [ __ ] holy crap yeah I'm surprised
that I like clothing definitely boosts
your confidence but you should build
your own confidence so I sent out an
email invite to the office for this
party today
turns out like 37 people want to come to
this party and actually reading that
number out loud made my heart start
pounding
I have never hosted anything really and
the only time I've ever thrown parties I
like disappear into a corner with like
three other people and ever just like
let everyone else do their thing this is
fun you guys are having a good time
right the party started out kind of
awkward seven or eight people showed up
all at once like before we had music
going before we had the booze setup
before like anything was ready I was
freaking out because it was just like
silence and co-workers were there hey
Gianni it's Jared wanted to perhaps
discuss any tips and/or tricks you have
stand on top of a table I'm true okay
that makes sense one thank you for
coming to if anyone wants to learn how
to make a righteous margarita I'm gonna
be teaching that right now I've been
doing it all week and it's been going
well so far
I feel warmer it's more partay for me I
can walk my bike
the party's fun pretty well I think
you'll having a good time walking around
today and my new outfit made me feel
really confident and like really
powerful but honestly once everything
got going it didn't really matter what I
was wearing
everything just kind of fell into place
all of this was just for him to realize
that he can do and be anyone that he
wants to be I can't do anyone he wants
to do that's not fine thanks for coming
oh yeah you had you had the party the
party it was a blast it wasn't scary it
was just fun like not taking it
seriously I think what would you say to
that person that would you a week ago
believe in yourself just seeing that it
was possible yeah gave me like so much
confidence slowed a homeboy from high
school to I think my job is done here
man
[Applause]
our entire friendship rests on the
success of this experience that's how
much good